situé à 1100 mètres d'altitude le
domaine archambault est une forêt de
transition se rencontrent les espèces d
eau et sel débat ce domaine porte le nom
d'un ancien maire de saint-pierre
conseiller général et député de la
réunion pierre edouard augustin
archambault situe au 19e kilomètre au
tampon cet espace de deux hectares est
un véritable îlot de forêt au coeur de
la ville alors l'histoire du domaine
archambault les allées la salle assez
singulière pour le coup donc
correspondre qu'à l'histoire de la
réunion a donc les fronts pionniers donc
son étendue balou d'allemagne ont donc
des grands défrichements à l'anglais et
puis il ya aussi une valorisation que
des terres et puis la villégiature
changement d'ère donc les gros
propriétaires comme monsieur archambault
donc j'avais un petit bout terrain sur
le thème du temps qu'on essaie donc de
taper dans les années 30
donc cette maison donc la maison
archambault est aujourd'hui acquis dans
les années 1990 par le conseil
départemental le site est géré depuis
2006 par le conservatoire des espaces
naturels de la réunion les ouvriers du
conservatoire ont d'abord travaillé à
libérer la forêt des pestes végétales
qui l'étouffé la restauration écologique
continue encore aujourd'hui
alors au début effectivement le site
était quand même très envahi un nous on
a repris le site que depuis quelques
années un donc il ya eu quand même un
gros travail de fait sur sur
l'aménagement des sentiers entre autres
si l'aménagement des sentiers la lutte
pour les exotiques entre autres la liane
cependant comme vous pouvez voir béria
vous par exemple sont des hommes qu on a
défriché qui est eux qui étaient très
envahi et diverses zones bien entendu au
niveau de la forêt en elle même dans
l'idéal c'est pouvoir éradiquer toutes
les espèces exotiques envahissantes et
donc pouvoir recréer donc
la forêt d'origine que monsieur
archambault a avait acquis à l'époque
dans les deux ans brière on trouve
toutes les espèces indigènes nécessaire
au reboisement des bacs à compost sur le
site permet de réutiliser les produits
de la lutte contre les pestes végétales
les déchets verts des plantes
envahissantes sont ainsi valorisés pour
favoriser la croissance des jeunes
plantes indigènes
tout ce que nous enlevons donc toute la
lutte que nous faisons contre la renault
ichi nous la liane pandore ou d'un
marron donc nous réutilisons ces déchets
verts donc en les broyant et en les
mettant à cordes et pas cap' compost que
nous utilisons donc pour la pépinière et
pour nos actions de plantation comme
chaque année le conseil départemental
met en place les week-ends nature durant
tout le mois d'octobre
l'occasion de profiter d'une visite
guidée du remarquable domaine
d'archambault afin d'apprécier la
diversité de la flore locale